do you know anything about the mental
impact on people after having an
abortion there's a lot of
international studies that show that
there's a lot of negative impact on
women
and if the woman is whether she's
pressured into that or she chooses it
freely
once you sort of have a recognition of
what actually happened like a human
being was killed
that's psychologically devastating i've
been privileged to talk to hundreds of
women
talk to them about their experiences and
the common thread is
anger at lies that they felt they were
told about their child and about
abortion
anger at the the people who may have
pressured them some studies say suicide
rate spikes for women
after an abortion depression spikes
a lot of addiction can spike and they
were left to grapple with these
consequences
and society was telling them oh you are
empowered you had an abortion you
practiced your choice
and they were left with these
devastating consequences so that's one
of the
injustices i think of abortion it kills
a baby but it also harms and hurts women